the view
[Musique]
chaude
eurostar
[Musique]
il est 18h15 sur la première
culture première jean-paul bilal bonsoir
bienvenue dans culture 1er au 2 pièces
de théâtre à l'honneur ce soir la
première est celle d'alain kamal martial
henry écrivain dramaturge maori son
titre un baiser à 2061 une pièce
futuriste et ito utopie celle sera
rejoué samedi au théâtre du grand marché
la second s'intitule mascarade
interprété par didier ibao et valérie
cros pièce écrite par papara robert et
sully andoche à voir samedi au théâtre
sous les arbres
une farce un drame politique universelle
édité par les éditions k'a ad'entrée
robert nous avons reçu le livre tout
juste arrivé dans l'île enfin il est
atypique dans le milieu de la musique
réunionnaise ne joue pas de sega ne
chante pas de maloya c'est notre faim
kaeser de ce soir son album se nomme
créole frank ingres romance son nom
d'artiste c'est will où il se sort
s'occupe de l'intermède musical de
culture première la réalisation
technique est signée bruno bas boom leur
nom sur la première action
culture première bonsoir didier ibao
soient rapprochés sur scène samedi la
pièce donc les cris pas barbara robert
lion d'or mascarade ils viennent sortir
d'édition cas à cette semaine sur scène
miles avait deux acteurs à eau avec un
temps modernes et madame valérie cross
c'est cross qui voudraient tester grand
ballet bross mascarade pour moi c'est
une farce une trame universel écrite en
2017 par sully andoche un trois
personnages principaux nains politiques
et syndicalistes
le fils caché du politique la femme du
syndicaliste que des aussi la maîtresse
du vieux politicards de députés de 70
ans
dena aussi le bonne journaliste à côté
et le coeur alors un vrai zambrocal
didier ibao ce pièce là oui un vrai café
la politique non mais les vrais en fait
nous nous l'avait invité cause un peu la
politique et la politique n'y crois pas
beaucoup de choses à dire et souvent
bientôt ce moulin et c'est un mascarade
politique c'est un mascara dessus si au
final pour moi la politique c'est un
vraie mascarade en ce moment surtout
koga la politique la réunion la
politique dans le monde partenariat qui
lie est menée même pour notamment
l'imposition il dirige le monde quoi et
nous laisserait nous laisse faire et du
coup notre envie de creuser un peu sa
critique un peu ça cause un pé fé
questionne un peu cristiano questionne
le monde
pourquoi nous les lacs aux données comme
ça des fois nous l'apprennent réponse
nous mais la question s'est fait poser
deux mondes la question ainsi que ça
nous fait cause pourquoi nous les comme
ça pourquoi nous laisse faire quoi alors
d'accord dans le monde europe ou
ailleurs mais n'a aussi parce que
excusez moi le bourguet le député
d'appel augus auguste gaillard ghallaoui
mais nos résultats notre auguste babet
risque absolu
après c'est chacun qui fait ivoire ce
qu'ils voient ça m'a fait ou sally vivre
à quoi parce que sur les lignes des
marques et des attentions toute
ressemblance avec des personnes ou des
situations existantes ou ayant existé
serait purement fortuite bien sûr tout à
fait tout à fait var et ferrer s'attirer
fera pas et voilà donc nous nous donne
pas de réponse du paris et nancy 12 -
nous nous laisse à autre prend le
spectacle comme zotti ils sont les
affaires comme en six ans et que ceux ci
décident saint-elme l'histoire bien lot
nous bien voilà ce qui comprend bien
dans la pièce syndicalistes politiques
même combat c'est à dire même affaire le
pouvoir le pouvoir l'argent la
corruption non c'est le christ youn m'en
fait justement le syndicaliste les
christian la question est ce que me doit
ré syndicat lys lui doit militer
ou alors il doit décider le politique
qui décide
le syndicat lys et milite les lys au bat
li saubade mais sauf que là dans la
pièce il est bien le cognac est long
comme drogue son nom d'amicale x110
calix femmes le syndicat mixe deux
syndicats l'x et dont les syndicalistes
et puis enfin il dit ben je crois que ça
change de bord mais ça devenir politique
c'est à dire qu'il veut devenir
exécutant il devait base des votes
peut-être non ab c'est non en fait à
zoug a baissé sur madame l'arc l'aseta
hop ou l'irak dans la politique willy
lité veut pas vraiment limité buropro
sont patentes camion bas pour les ventes
barak est bio sans additif ce matin que
les machins donc le madame enfants elle
a travaillé un peu dans son dos quoi
attention for me alors en fait nous
l'apprennent aussi un texte de
shakespeare macbeth que c'est un peu
aussi sa dent dans macbeth enfin le
madame vieille tous ali alex chez le roi
pour lui prend la place le roy et denis
leroy quoi à l'as à la salle africart
alors et comique parce qu'au début de la
pire série commence alors ne va dire
quand même et n'a donc deux journalistes
qui intervient aussi dans les pièces ne
dira pas tout le temps
bon ok et puis il ya aussi deux corps y
fait comme dans la le théâtre antique
voilà j'avais besoin ça c'est une façon
de du plus haut que de rajouter de la
parole à la parole nous va dire ne
commentant fait banal commande le
coryphée en général y il commente la
cité unique au monde ce qui se passe
dans la cité est liée là comme poser des
questions morales y saint-pé xi faut il
questionne aussi cet espace sur la scène
en direct commenté par le cur alors il
commence fort le afférents parce que bon
on commence à nous horrifier l'accent du
salat permise et a nommé gâte un peu
guette azote assister à l'appareil 2 3
lorsque la booth aspects à l'appeler
pour coin isolé la photo j spu look et
pour fait lever pour gomis par la bouche
si zot lé là pour critiquer effet rambo
optique et décale espèce peu passif
l'effort quand même
ben oui les fon aura besoin de fonds n'a
besoin veille un peu les consciences de
ses brebis égarées dans la savane et du
profit de la déculturation comme il dit
la demande dans le texte alors le madame
mademoiselle rose lauriers je suppose
que les par hasard parce que leur gaieté
de monza si vous mangez trop
oui et on espère que ça se passe en
dévoile tout non madame lidoine espèces
manger son amant ben oui et de la moelle
gagne et aux malades
ah oui tout à fait oui mais le frp la
vengeance ils ont envahi un p je crois
que la vengeance en 38 c'est parce que
tout lille a envie le pouvoir pour son
bonhomme bello a dit pluie alors lille
envie de pouvoir c'est madame les envies
de pouvoir il a invité et lisse au
caisson violemment il a pas cela mais
avant libération laisse kablia sialique
et la succession l'assuré qui est née
ouaga le pouvoir alors opus ne pas pas
la population il appelle à l'est c'est
l'esprit d'équipé seule femme qui dit ça
ou c'est l'un d'entre eux c'est la
présentation c'est notre journaliste
présente année comme papa la population
l'uson à michel debré ça comme média où
chacun y voit sa pote que salif et voit
quoi il ya moins le texte appelait le
text is it pas michel debré mais c'est
une fois michel debré et oui la vie
peut-être il va voir et micro il faut
bien voir
bon alors là coup de tête aussi dedans
tu as oui tout à fait à toutes et à tous
parce que la dite halal a donc mais m'a
pas merdé voile c'est que rose
en fait c'est la maîtresse du député de
70 ans
et comme par hasard le rose les marier
avec
le garçon du député mais parce que ce
n'est pas son papa être 100 députés
abbaoui il connaît pas que le député se
sont pas pas moi c'est un espèce et nos
telenovelas picon et karine ratia où il
ya de la matière d'accord ok mais sont
bien puisque de toute façon
est-ce qu'il va jusqu'au bout du
manganèse qui va réussir il faut y voir
la pièce pour telle est la question
parce qu'à un moment ils posent à des
commandes il est sans appel une fois
n'est pas coutume on a vu quelque part
il a tout bien d'autres hobbies
c'est la validation de mais
c'est parce que sa question le fait de s
kelly doit rester juin l'agglo cohérente
en politique pour tous se battent au
final c'est la question c'est vraiment
hyper ali là dessus en mêlée mais
d'étonner parce que bon ce lion d'or par
robin mais je n'ai pas lu bien celui
andoche et un bouddha points vingt ans
ça beau quand même à 60 ans ou pas trop
loin samson l'écriture les quand même
moderne à bali et il reste dans le
modernisme olena qualité à lomé s'est
retrouvé ben voilà la mal à retrouver
d'affaires avance à la legros un moment
ni dit cui cui khalkhal 410 les lieux à
l'arrivée pour lever pjak pjak 110 et
puis elle y parle elle n'est pas de son
énergie et en fait c'était l'égérie pas
trop cultivé nom de madame l'a abolie
dit qu'on lui fait comme ligue 1
malheureusement ils ressemblent pour
moins bonnes madame y suivent parfois
bonne politique ed toujours devant écrit
untel untel untel vote pou li votre ceci
votre seul à faire appel à moi un peu ça
se madame là bas chaque année rappelle
qu'au mieux oui tout à fait alors me
disais que l'écriture sully les modèles
parce que n'ayant pas de trois mots
merkel schéma l'avait marqué potentats
la lame et après comment on fait comme
ça voici ces sully ou barbara l'écrit un
des deux hommes éditions de 3 2 3 rails
travaillant lycéen n'a de trois gros
mots aussi dedans
c'est l'enseignant ouais d'accord quand
il est conseillé elhorga jeune fille
s'est dit conscient qu'au sénégal
euphorique en ce moment c'est pas mais
ce n'est pas le bouc c'est le formule
peut-être jusqu'à oui risque des scop
mais pas sur combien ce sont nous les
invitons tous les deux nous les deux à
moins de voir eric roth et nous
interprète plusieurs personnages
d'ailleurs nous les masques et donc du
fait d'être masqué permettent à nous
jouer plusieurs rôles en l'adsa aussi
quoi alors à propos des masques
normalement le spectacle doit seul mois
de mars
juste un petit joueur avant de mon
abonnement de masques donc nous tu es
obligé arrête le spectacle et puis nous
l'a arrêté et du coup on a fait
refabrique le bahamas et là nous avons
commencé en septembre dans le temps il
prend en général où tu es moche et
fabrique le mas qui appellera stiefel
c'est un suisse y habite paris et en
général il prend avait pris un mois un
mois et demi pour faire masquer la
province un peu le temps pour combien
max la lan à 3 dans le spectacle mais la
volane où à peu près 6 masque avec déjà
six de fabriquer mais la volt il doit ne
pas aussi la retrouve le bonne volée
revel n'a pas retrouvé non ça trouve
hold up
alors la pièce la pièce a été jouée
comme une fois déjà les samedis jouer
dans mascarade nous l'a joué cinq fois
qu'être sous les abbés une fois au lycée
geoffroy là et dernièrement bonne maman
y accroche à rouiba maillard crois qu'il
est contre la syrie ni à tijuana de
trois gros mots de drainage et 3 pas
trop et bizarrement bamako l'agneau à
respirer pétitions ont été choqués par
le n2o des ajustements il fait exprès
comme say showcases hot et tu vois que
quand il dit ça il faut beaucoup de
minutie nouvelle un côté pédagogique de
la chose qua non que choses en
préparation pour plus tard avec eux
il va aux compagnies là en fait le
compagnon fénols un autre spectacle
victoire ma droite voire au savon
novembre nous ça et moi tout année en
france en algérie nous ça tourne le
spectacle spectacle la guerre 14 18
donc nous nasa et puis l'année prochaine
nous continuer tout une mascarade et
nous confie tignes et fait tout une
victoire magloire hockey en tout cas
didier ibao messi ou là des passable ou
nice rendezvous dénonçait la grand
marché la balle un cabas soyons déjà
mais là ça me rappelle que donc
mascarade donc sully andoche barbra
robert le livre la sortie semaine ici
l'arrivée micro lundi vincenti donc aux
éditions rakaa andré robert andré robèr
voilà mezali mais c'est aussi parce
qu'il ya des postes pour moi tout de
suite que ce magal yaya soir voilà donc
si tu veux acheter ces 15 euros mais
c'est inadmissible et il a filé les
nouveaux tournois de bones habitait
d'ailleurs monsieur culture première
[Musique]
kramer
en parler à ton petit coach chocolat
mais qu'elles n'ont pas su agen mur
juste on comprend à me entier après ces
mois ferme a le goût tout chocolat le
goût toujours co la nana
[Musique]
c'est grâce à ma réserve pour ces
patrons site ou non les goûts tout c'est
le canevas pour
affaire de goût les deux pays jouent
elles aussi rogala bjm qu'un cerveau tu
es cambouis chez venir juste copan
ammann entier nous appartient aux play
offs approuvées à seulement affaire m'a
bien beau gatier le coup tout chocolat
le goût toujours konami juste copro à
monde entier et pas seulement faire un
petit coucou tout chocolat le court
toujours
quand la nano robots c'était donc que
will notre deuxième éviter qu'ils mènent
donc interpréter chocolat un des six
morceaux de de son album qui va sortir
de qui s'appelle créoles faac une
romance est une auto pour les ressources
et romance et à ses romans ayrault seuls
5 et romance dans une autoproduction
wilbon soir alors son vrai nom c'est
wilfrid weiss huningue mené les actes
eux manseng coûte 75 à saint-louis 43
ans jeune homme il a vécu entre l'art
est un endroit déjà c'est ça ouais
monaco ou que vous l'avez 33 ces centres
or ces fûts fut un temps voilà il a vécu
de la réunion et la france font des
drisses james brown slight au nom de
famille parce que portent les marques et
sly stone woody family stone merci et
bien d'autres il apprend la guitare en
autodidacte étudie les mathématiques ce
dans plusieurs formations musicales bien
sûr en 2009 retour à la réunion 9 ans
plus tard ils sortent donc son premier
ep
combien de temps pour réaliser ce 1er
avril un premier européen oui bien sûr
la botte ouais en fait à la base c'était
pas prévu de vraiment de faire un ep
c'était de mettre en forme des morceaux
et de fil en aiguille sa partie sur le
parti sur l'idée de faire le p mais donc
ça a pris deux ans alors a pris deux ans
quand même le matin monsieur gaillard
côté au fait ça quand même
spécialiste en la matière c'est mamie 10
juin c'est parce qu'elle est prononcée
roanne ou juan juan rozoff étaient
présents que c'est qui ce monsieur à
roanne rosacée
et le grand patron la fun mais en cross
dia la funk en france c'est encore trop
réducteur c'est un bricoleur de génie
comme éthique c'est un génie dur
maintenant les bricoleurs médicaux de la
jenny peut-être alors laisser quelqu'un
vraiment très pointue dans la musique
notamment en france et conduit surtout
par rapport aux femmes c'est le et
appelle le président français qui
prononce la roche
il est vrai que tout le monde se
l'arrachent ce juan rozoff rousseau la
rencontre a dû ou déjà m'a rencontrée
sur une brocante nepali la cassette de
son premier album que matthew peuvent
espérer moyens coûtent pas mcma du volet
mais parce que thomas trouve la pochette
cool et c'était l'époque où menés en
france tu vois étudiants est vraiment ma
vraiment accroché sur sa musique et puis
de fil en aiguille à force d'aller voir
ce pari le grand conseil a ben alors moi
à miami comme ça on n'a pas deux ou
trois extraits de l'album
la première mal accroche tout de suite
parce que bonobo 1000 m2 finck
mais ensuite parce qu'il rappelle moi un
musicien le manager ou ce qui me plaît
pas sur l'écouté entre temps michael
fincke et wachovia
on va convenir mois mais même ceux ci la
beauté plus chaloupé les plus marquées
etc
mais bon c'est un truc que miyama
lorsqu'on l'écouté michael frank school
a aimé ou pas dans cette afrique à ce
que m'a aimé c'est le côté ma troupe
mamma compris qu'on veut dire parce que
vous luttez musique anglaise michael
frank c'est pas possible que je connais
pas tu vois si ça ressemble à ce que la
voix c'est vraiment quelque chose et
nenê touche exotique dans sa villa
d'ailleurs il fait un peu de trucs un
peu samba magento ça jazze it ou alors
le clip chez r'n'b hausse inattendue des
membres morceau programmation années 80
3 mais chanter ah bon c'est pas de
chocolat que la composer avec un autre
monde me croire c'est ça oui avec
raymond le syli le texte voilà le texte
vous avez une caution féminine pour le
texte
justement il tombe bien parce que l'on
regarde le clip hyper sensuelle le clip
chocolat la grippe était trop mais très
sensuelle quand même
le bien le chocolat qui coule pas ça les
gros plans quand même assez subjectif
mais pas trop mais là où il faut bon
mais suppose que le réalisateur du fait
plaisir à l'école d'art deleasa dont
tout le monde d'accord et comme un appel
au réalisateur c'est michael gray ces
six autres sur l'onglet pas en français
à cause c'est le concept chanter dans la
langue où les mots et vient manière la
plus simple de chanter pour moi les mots
en créole dans là pour la musique
nationale
ouais ouais trouve isson après déjà
c'est important pour moi niveau de la
musique c'est pouvoir donner ce côté
personnel c'est-à-dire mureaux contre
lui reconnaît maintenant s'ils me suis
fait un truc elle est super même
recrutement de danse et même veine qu'un
pas faire comme ils intéressent pas moi
donc il faut que nous reconnaît amendant
déjà le meilleur moyen surtout si vous
aussi en mélangeant avec finck r'n'b
tout ça est pour moi tu es une évidence
deux sont ancrés à prêter pas facile
n'est pas facile parce que déjà tout ce
qui est fun car nba en général c'est pas
renoncé c'est en anglais les expériences
en français en général ils sonnent pas
trop à part juan rozoff grande influence
pour moi parce que justement m'a compris
de mâcon prime a vu que voilà où se
façonne ses musiques afro américaines
dans une autre langue que l'anglais
ce qu'il a fait en français et en
espagnol donc méfaits en créole époux
mal et naturel après le créole quoi
alors non on n'a qu'à alain kamal
martial collet l'a donc nos invités que
les écrivains dramaturges à la caméra
rapprochez vous du micro alors vous avez
aimé la musique
enfin elle va s'origine al commun du
funk en créole je sais pas si ça peut se
faire aussi en maillot et pourquoi pas
mais un peu sur un schéma aurait ça
c'est fait et j'ai trouvé l'histoire la
couleur créole dans le cinq
très original alors comment le monde
la audi le premier assaf erreur de ma
part à faire ce genre de musique ici à
la réunion on va en tous les cas en
créole avec des textes en créole avec
outre itma autorit minc
comment le public l'a cueilli sa manière
générale tout est plutôt positif
après c'est vrai que des fois je vais
des morceaux un peu comme ça c'est cet
amour si les projets non mais bon c'est
pas vous faut que les gens y accroche y
accroche il reste là mais si c'est au
prix quoi c'est assez froid ou paroisse
sur 7 à montceau ou même par exemple
aller coûte à des camarades au début
qu'à écouter bout de 30 secondes quand
même le morceau afin de commencer alors
que toi parce que là la musique tout ça
il rappelle le côté américain alors et
pourquoi cette volonté délibérée ou nana
d'avocats pêcher ou de lignes thouarcé
août sur scène n'ont même pas c'est un
style c'est comme ça au début c'était
comme ça reconnaît pas moins soir
justement en parlant de l'avant après
[Musique]
c'est aussi pour casser un cliché en
général comme angie au funk mais ça
c'est un cliché occidentale c'est funk
c'est on met des perruques on met des
pantalons pattes d'eph on met des
chemises alain et puis non c'est pas ça
il ya plein de gars de mouvements fans
ce projet m'habille comme ça
mais pas de quoi quoi mais jean-paul
c'était les annexer des incendies à
mettre un pantalon pattes d'eph c'était
un vote à présent tous les jours c'était
oui ça va à la mort comme sakho oui mais
il est quand même là la contribué à
faire que de fins de l'ailier aussi à ça
toute leur imagination tous et tous ces
groupes la wind and fire dont c'était
les années 80 les années 80 c'est aussi
les vêtements de l'époque d'accord à ce
que veut dire mais maintenant je veux
dire c'est là des groupes comme caméo
des groupes de fin à ces cuirs noirs ça
d'oiseaux c'est un petit peu ça ouais
voilà même bien ce côté là aussi
tranchant quoi ressentir un choc un
petit peu quoi au choc ou provoquent way
peut-être provoque en moi en tout cas
interpellé sur quelque chose sur
invitation à domat nous alors plusieurs
eux mais par des interprétations c'est
pas le mot plusieurs donc scène ici déjà
à la réunion où ça et c'est quoi les
prochains auront alors
facile mais on a fait le pas mal de haut
niveau des barres déjà des rondavelles
apprenait qu'elle vient trop tôt
naviguait avec fff
l'espace saint paul le pitch i will be
chic de diamants manapany festival bon
et patrick banon
comment alors justement comment bones et
la vie y accroche ou pas je ne l'avais
connais pas est ce que n'est vraiment
pas franchement conseillez moi non je
n'ai d'autre part de nos premières petit
coup de peinture la musique que nos
jeunes
et puis c'est pas le style de musique
que les élèves écoutent combat n'avait
pas son lycée l'an collège là ma fille
comme les au lycée elle y donne les
faits au québec à wil moi même
personnellement mais plutôt que mal à
accrocher la cauchie seul album il se
peut qu'on aura un deuxième bar hui si
on retravaille le deuxième un projet
toujours avec aurait deux mots wi lan à
cyril schmidt
donc il aurait aussi mis créole n'a
jamais l'oreille il ya dix ou vingt dix
bon après que semaine après la dernière
et c'est à la guitare
samcon excellent johan santana la basse
éric havane au clavier d'accord je
n'osais morceau avant nous attaquent
avec halak à martial problèmes auxquels
dans le morceau et le qui viennent y
appelle reste encore fort comme cette
balade
[Musique]
ouais restaurant côté les amants salomon
précieux pour le secret est on conte
côtier moi ma besoins et envies du coup
les faits les années musulin ont souvent
au caire ont la nouaille donne fou la
firme sentiments à noter comme les
petits assemblée et tout ça là dessus
ces femmes des oies restants
pour les mon salon mon pc mon lot
secrets restants con côté
- mme a besoin pas m'attire l'entrée
sens bien c'est pas vrai non non tu n'as
pas maps ou répondre - conforte - et
quel côté au soleil prenez nous donnait
les mêmes regrets
freda - la paix nous la paix
reste encore pour tiennent les monts
salomon play sur mon l'eau sucrée
restant encore courtiers
un mal
[Musique]
non non
robert on la trouve le son
pau arrivent d'autres moins mais tu
crois pis rien et là où vient on la
trouve le moyen pour un voyage sans fin
et dans mon rêve où vient dictée pas
moins
on la trouve le sommet a pour arrive
cote r - c'est quoi puis rien et là où
viens viens
on la trouve le moyen aboya sans feu
dans mon rêve quintilla mois
reste encore pour dia - les monts soeur
mon précieux mon l'eau sucrée
les tangos témoins mahbod soir
[Musique]
culture première c'était will donc qui
nous interpréter reste encore extrait
donc de son premier album à l'hormadi de
bêtises c'est fincke et romance volume 1
ça même même nom elle redit des femmes
créoles et merci oui c'est will c'est
pas du level collet c'est w.illi.am
points elle voit là parce que notre
huile de souscrire ou sur youtube
donc c'est pour ça il voulu préciser
w.illi.am points elle devrait vite et
nous viennent mayotte pas très connu du
grand public réunionnais pourtant alain
kamal marcel henry titulaire d'un
doctorat de littérature française et
francophone a déjà commis cette
production dont un baiser à 61 l'objet
de sa venue ce soir dans ce studio
il a déjà effectué une résidence
d'écriture dans le limousin était invité
au festival d'avignon en 2007 effectué
une résidence au grand marché au
mozambique
il n'est plus directeur de la culture
conseil départemental de mayotte
il a été pendant quelques années il a
sévi en béziat 2061 est l'histoire d'une
ville utopique en béziat sur scène une
récitante un soliloque de près d'une
heure entre coupé accompagné de musique
la récitante part de me mame sarif ou
qui tels halakha mars avec eux raconte
elle alors oui mam sarif où ça signifie
déjà celui qui se lève
ça servira c'est un schéma aurait en
langue malaise alors ça pourrait
symboliser tout aux personnes qui dans
un coin de ce monde à porter sur son dos
l'un destiné de son peuple et notamment
ici du peuple de la diaspora africaine
sortie de the media que ce soit à rayons
que sont l essca rosie comme ailleurs
ce soit aussi barks son brésil partout
il ya eu dérive un pari fou qui vont du
hem en donner pour tes un combat pour la
liberté des hommes alors son bizia 2061
au début donc de la pièce il ya donc une
vidéo
on va donc les fameuses chutes du
zambèze où les vagues victoria falls
sens bizarre c'est une ville de votre
imagination ou alors ses rapports avec
quelque chose de particulier ça a un
rapport avec la source mais aussi le
devenir
tous les deux en même temps parce qu'il
faut savoir que on se pose jamais la
question de comment se fait-il que à un
moment donné dans cette région du monde
toutes les tous les peuples venez ici
pour converser alors soir cazin médias
autour du fleuve un vision zombies qu il
y avait un grand port qui s'appelait
sioule
hélas hélas ont trouvé vraiment l'or
alors les asiatiques venaient
austronésiennes les arabes
puis après beaucoup plus tard les
européens et le marcquois qui est
l'ethnie ou la communauté la plus vendue
une autre région
dur à la traite négrière est originaire
en grande partie de cette bd mais c'est
aussi un média c'est aussi un flux avec
des légendes parfois et des histoires
magnifiques qui m'ont inspiré dans cette
écriture et pour moi c'est à la fois
source de l'idée d'émancipation mais
également de venir puisque autour d 1
10e nous retrouvons transcender tous
quelque part dans cette région des
enfants de m alors vous parlez donc
d'une ville arrêtez moi si je me trompe
une ville quand même une ville utopique
vous parlez de 2060 et alors quand je
dis ce qu'il ya un mode d'écriture
espaces réels ou imaginaires actuel ou
passé ce sont des lieux de vie qui passe
au fil de leur transformation parfois
violent dominateur au plein d'espoir et
prometteur c'est la révolution jusqu'à
la cité u topie espace irréel car non
encore accompli le zambezi à 2061 kiné
de l'inspiration d'un poète
ça peut être des grandes idées du
militantisme africain pour la liberté
des blocs alors après cité des libertés
sont béziat réalise le rêve des grands
humanistes et le rend hommage et plus
loin vous parlez vous dites zones béziat
et justement là où les grandes valeurs
des intellectuels noirs celle définie
comme promesse de bonheur se sont
réalisés se sont se sont réalisées en
2061 nous ça en 2018 à la alors là il ya
une incompréhension alors elles vont
engendrer la comédienne dit je pointe
malades sur le futur antérieur d'un à
venir a annoncé mais pas encore accompli
c'est à dire que dans l'esprit du texte
on se situe pas dans un présent qui est
contemporain mais c'est un présent qui
est advenu
alors c'est ça qu'on est dans l'utopie
utopie c'est ça veut dire quoi
c'est le
nulle part mais on sait alors c'est très
important de souligner sa cause et que
tous les peuples rêve son graal beaucoup
de notre passé mais quelque part notre
futur nous échappent à ce concours très
rarement le jure ce que nous pouvons
accomplir et dans un béziat c'est
quelque part c'est bien connu dans
l'irréel l'utopie mais une utopie qui
peut devenir réalité si nous voulons
s'il nous pensons être arabe capable de
maîtriser notre destin dans cette région
se sont munis veau haché les gens ont
écrit les gens vont parler je suis
fortement ainsi influencé par un écran
intellectuels dont baqouba est tous les
restes ailleurs mais aussi ceux d'ici
notre main une femme mahoraise n'diaye
qui a apporté aussi le rêve du congo le
congo c'est à dire que tous les autres
hommes et toutes les femmes qui vont
militer pour nos populations qui sont
vos lumières des populations gère de
l'afrique qui sont encore soumises dans
oui j'étais sûr qu'ils sont encore
soumises dans ces villes où nous vivons
sous vide ne sont plus de 2 du
capitalisme 2
dustrit des finances nous sommes que
quelque part des êtres qui servent pour
en faire rouler la machine on le fait
quand j'étais mais le capital ne nous
appartiennent pas et la domination dans
le rêve de tous ces hommes ces traités
dans des fosses et dans un seul sens
trouver la place notre place nous
originaire d'afrique qui avons été à 201
esclaves et durera deux cents à
coloniser quelque part comment nous pour
vous dans un sursaut arriver à dépasser
ses chaînes kim qu ils sont encore là
faut pas penser que la sonabhy
décolonisation ces scènes sont encore là
comment sommes nous capables de dépasser
alors les clés sont là c'est juste
demain ce rêve porté par des gens qui
ont parlé des marques et luther king des
balles commises et nous on va des
savoirs à machel des daniel honoré visée
laser et daniel honoré puisqu'on voit de
demeurer sur scène en pleine rue
c'est un lyonnais on est d'accord tout à
fait mais il n'est pas complètement
africain ces malgaches
quelque part c'est celle africains nous
sommes des africains cécilia du chinois
il ya des chinois en vie mais nous
sommes des africains à partir du moment
où on est dans cette région du monde on
est déjà là d afrique et parce qu'on
fait partie de l'afrique faut pas le
renier et daniel honoré il a des
origines aussi malgaches et les mariages
las vegas et l'afrique mayotte c'est
l'afrique c'est-à-dire d'un coup
n'admettra pas déjà que notre condition
et celle de la casse en s'invitant sur
notre sort ou pleurnicher et savoir qu'
il y à un autre monde qui est arrivé ici
depuis des cibles qui a fait des dominés
des dominants et que nous sommes dans la
condition de dominer notre travail dans
le futur et peut-être d'être dans ce
rapport au changement quel changement
qui donc consisté à trouver une place
qui quelque part anvers ou régule le
rapport entre les communautés regarder
partout où vous êtes ce choix d'un
arrive ce soir
ada l'amour nairobi que ce soit mam ou
jamais que tout même asséné
c'est quoi le rapport à l'argent le cros
rapport ces clips des tiers cet argent
qui fait que tous les matins nous nous
lèverons pour aller courir derrière
c'est qui qui détient sa déception tout
pâle à la descendance africaine est pas
la diaspora c'est ce que je disais il ya
quelques temps au à ce micro je suis à
quel moment mais je disais que mon avis
il y avait un constat qu'avait été fait
et pas y avait des études qui a été fait
à quelques années que tous ceux qui sont
descendants d'africains dans des pays
qui ont été colonisés
ils sont pratiquement tous en bas de la
strate sociale sabah et le pourquoi
c'est quoi le pourquoi c'est qu'en
réalité à une machine qui n'est pas une
machine qui sévit uniquement à laguiole
qui a des ramifications dans le monde et
qu'ils contrôlent vous n'êtes pas
paraître complot quand même c'est pas un
complot mais cessons d'essayer de nous
exploiter l'homme pour produire une
richesse et celle ont exploité ces omlt
le blog de cette région parle
aujourd'hui du sud
et bravo mais les intellectuels noirs
durant des décennies ont évoqué cette
idée est simple c'est ce qu'il a fait
dans les textes sont à couper l'alarmé
l'immense arif au basket landes avaient
défilé lustré selon ce rapport qu'on re
découvrant ce texte
c'est cette langue qui est la même non
pas la langue créole ou shimaoré ou
malgache mais cette langue qui dit la
même chose partout il faut
l'émancipation de ses c'est vraiment le
bout de la langue comme si c'était une
seule langue qui est parlée qui est qui
est porté par tous ces intellectuels
voix une seule et même voix et on a
tendance à l'oublier
et si un moment dans cette région je
parle surtout de cette région des
originaires
nous constatons que nous avons les mêmes
problèmes et que cette industrie qui
nous a sortis de l'afrique pour certains
qui nous a exploité pendant 500 ans est
toujours restée maîtresse dans le dessus
capital et qu'il s'agit pour nous
d'arriver à le comprendre pour pouvoir
tourner vers l'avenir nous uniquement
vers notre passé mais 2070 l'avenir les
indépendances
or un siècle d'accord les indépendances
alors je dis rawyl de se préparer en
entendant puisque dans quelques instants
on va retrouver france info il faudra
laisser la place donc à notre consoeur
qui arrive dans juste rapidement vous
disiez le discours est prophétique il
compte votre la ville comme le lieu où
doit se réaliser
le désir d'un manque de 5,5 d'esclavagé
de colonisation là j'ai pas compris
alors tous ceux sur un port s'élargira
non pas seulement par les idées la
parole mais aussi un transforma la ville
pour qu'il y ait plus un centre ville
commercial avec des gens riches qui
habille qui ont l'argent et des
faubourgs au chaudron ou ailleurs où les
gens sont exclues de ça voudrait casser
jura pour à la vie que le peuple ozzy et
sa part de ville dans les centres villes
merci alain canam kamal martial je
rappelle que votre pièce est de nouveau
joué au théâtre du grand marché aux cdo
et samedi à 20 heures c'est bien ça à 15
heures à 15 heures plus tôt oui on
t'aime une aiguille il va jouer jusqu'à
19h mais là tu élimines va prendre le
dessus pour nous on passe à la radio
bonne soirée en tous les cas sur réunion
1ère et dans culture premier on se
retrouve la semaine verte et blanche
merci à louis qui nous est après tout
cette comptine pour enfant qui fait
pschitt
tu es mal à pour ouvrir fruits ou sucrés
ton ali et sa moue le temps tu as lu le
mouvement à mon fils tu as vu comme l a
affirmé four à th
prends mon main nous ça en voyage tout
en sont vraiment
vraiment
ma famille mon
hamon nous
sandy n'a compris moi
avec
[Musique]
loin dans mon coeur me quoi toutes les
possibles le père pensant vais loin dans
mon coeur me croit toutes les peaux si
nou pé trouve limitée loin dans mon
coeur me croit toutes les peaux si nous
paie encore 100 loin dans mon coeur me
croit toutes les peaux si nou pé trouve
li était en
pays
bientôt côté - m'a raconté l'histoire au
bout pas besoin pour la paire louvre m'a
profiteurs moment avant le temps et rapa
nous les lacs ou somme ou par appel à ou
petit réseau ma place à un obus pas tout
ça là les ans ou un petit look hippie qu
un refrain baguette magique
les radios 19h sur la gfa la première
heure de retenue et le flash de france
info est tous fort c'est le rendez vous
incontournable on savait que c'était
magnifique de jouer
l'événement qui approche à grands pas ou
est-ce que des milliers de personnes de
la réunion des quatre coins du monde
attendent avec beaucoup d'impatience
jours après à l'heure du débat tout
sport le magazine de la rédaction tous
les vendredi à 18h15 sur la première
dimanche 28 octobre c'est la journée
départementale des personnes âgées le
département où vous donne rendez vous
aux acides et arcade sont au tampon de
9h à 16h30 au programme la messe
animation bal retrouver des stands
d'information du département et de ses
partenaires profiter du village agricole
avec les producteurs pays
rendez vous dimanche 28 octobre oaci
dr400 au tampon le département aux côtés
de nos aînés
[Musique]
le gouvernement